welcome to architecting with google
cloud
our topic today is going to be desktop
apps and cloud
it might not seem like an obvious
combination
but let's dig in so hi everybody i'm
brian and i'm an engineer helping users
with infrastructure at google cloud
and one of the architectural challenges
that we run into often is around network
latency
and
how to get people connected with their
desktop apps to the back end systems
running somewhere else you know often in
cloud
and
depending on where they are that latency
can get pretty high
and if there's multiple round trips it
can get fairly slow
so one
common pattern for for dealing with this
is to actually move the desktop
application closer to the database
and
then connect to that remotely like with
a remote desktop
application of some kind so you have a
window into the application running
elsewhere on a vm perhaps
next to the database
and that keeps the really chatty stuff
there and then you kind of get a window
into this app um
and to explore that further um we've got
uh rick from citrix here today and
citrix
they have been for a long time focusing
on tools to help make this pattern
easy and reliable
easy as possible to run so thank you for
coming rick what do you do at citrix
pleasure thanks for uh thanks for having
me today brian
uh well i've actually i've made pretty
much my entire it career around citrix
technologies
uh for longer than i care to
unveil in such a public forum but uh the
last three years i've actually been at
citrix working in the strategic
alliances team focusing on one of our
most important technology partners
that's google so i'm a solution
architect and all my time has been spent
at the intersection of google
technologies and citrix technologies and
the problems we solve and the solutions
we have market together
fantastic so we have exactly the right
person here
um
i
um my citrix experience is mostly i
think you know maybe from 20 years ago
where you know you use citrix to connect
to some like ms office applications or
you know sap or like lotus notes or
something uh off somewhere else i
imagine it's changed a bit since then um
is that still a common pattern or like
how are they you know
i
i imagine a lot has changed anyway
a lot has definitely changed all the way
up and down the stack
but if you consider the the fundamentals
of the virtualization solution to be
remote remotely connecting to an
application running on a different host
the fundamentals of the technology are
still the same uh they're still used to
solve a lot of the same problems but the
problem set that it's solving now has
actually gotten dramatically bigger and
we could tell a little bit about that as
we work our way through here
uh but the the citrix of today i mean
it's been around for
quite some time it's it's been solving
problems for enterprise i.t customers
around secure access application
delivery and even networking
technologies believe it or not
for well over 25 years
but back in the day say in the 20 25
years ago
the technology stack called wind frame
or metaframe at the time
was pitched as a remote access solution
and you know it it took the the model
if we look at corporate i.t back in that
day
it was typically enterprise would build
a data center it was their own building
they built their entire stack from
cooling and cabling all the way up
through cpu network uh to a secure
perimeter they build their own
applications that they'd run their app
stack inside of the data center they'd
install the app on their client
computers who were in a lot of cases in
that same office
clients would connect to their apps
client server was a thing
and uh and they were happy
well that use case started to fall down
as the complexity of it and users
expectations started to change
so as organizations started to to bring
in multiple data centers uh multiple
remote offices mergers and acquisitions
offshoring of developers you know
a very very broad range of different
influences started to come in
and that model where you run client-side
xc
uh on a client device
and server-side you know connecting to
the server side we'd had really chatty
protocols and stuff that we would
develop to back then
that model would break down so people
would leverage
session remoting as we'd consider it
today and
desktop and app virtualization
has a way to deliver applications to
users on whatever device they happen to
be via corporate owned or byo
uh on over whatever type of a network
the user happened to be on
that was kind of the foundation and that
foundation of the solution is still in
play still solving problems for
customers
uh today
we do however call it something a little
bit different today today we'd call it
uh vdi is the a popular term that we
would call that kind of uh solution
pattern and that's short for virtual
desktop infrastructure gotcha so virtual
desktop infrastructure what
what does that look like concretely for
folks today it you know are they still
running it all on their own data centers
what does it look like today so some
customers are still running it in their
own data centers and we call it vdi
today oddly enough
but
it's it's a bit different
so you'll hear the term das or desktop
as a service used today and while the
fundamentals of the solution are the
same
it's essentially a solution spectrum at
one end of the solution you've got all
customer managed infrastructure software
components control playing everything
typically on on stuff that they've
bought
in a perpetual manner and then built up
on stuff that they own as well
the other end of the spectrum with
desktop as a service similar to
infrastructure as a service database you
know all the as a services
that modern networking and cloud
technologies have brought us
um so you've got a bit of a continuum
so what we uh there are customers that
still run what we call daz today with a
citrix
control plan that they build and manage
their own in their own data center
but then at the other end of the
spectrum you've got the customers that
have evolved or maybe even started
in the cloud right the whole born in the
cloud type of generation
and so you know you've got it while
you've got a continuum in between there
uh at the far end of the spectrum and
the daz end of the spectrum
instead of the customer buying building
managing and maintaining the entire
stack top to bottom
they consume managed services or cloud
services from providers such as google
and
admittedly also citrix
and so in doing so they can focus on
the core business stuff that adds value
to their business and and offload these
specialized technology functions to the
experts
and then we we end up being responsible
for managing and maintaining and
updating and securing and providing high
availability and and all those kinds of
things
so it's a it's it's a bit of a different
world still the core of the technology
stack is the same
got it and
if i'm if i'm hearing this right it
sounds like another instance of this
pattern people sometimes called move and
improve you know where you take an
existing app you you kind of move it
over into cloud and then you start
iteratively adding kind of more managed
bits to it or more integrations to other
things
to make it work better
so for folks who are
currently running citrix in their own
data centers
what what does this move and improve
path look like concretely you know for
them
so you've got you've got essentially two
different components i'm simplifying
things a little bit but if you want to
call the
the two customer managed components in
the vdi model
you could call the control plane the
virtualization control plane that's what
i was talking about where they get the
software from citrix they download it
they install it on their own stuff
and then what we call the vdas
and the vdas stands for virtual delivery
agent it's simply a virtual machine that
has r vda software installed on it
and that's what virtualizes the user
interface and remotes it to the user
somewhere else
so if you think about any any deployment
of citrix virtualization technology you
got a control plane and you've got the
customer managed components or the vdas
so
as customers adopt cloud and cloud
technologies
you know they've got to have some
measure of infrastructure up in the
cloud in order to put an application up
there
right so in the google world that's
typically a landing zone they have to
have a landing zone they got to connect
that landing zone to their corporate
data center their their their old
self-managed stuff
once they got their landing zone then
they can start to extend services such
as active directory
up into the cloud and they can also
start moving applications like say you
know all the infrastructure to support
sap
or you know any other number of
corporate applications moving those from
on-prem up into the cloud
so the logical move you would expect is
if you want to have the application
running next to the data
which you do because that's where you
that's how you provide the best
performance right
is to take the vdas and move the vas up
into the cloud
well that's absolutely something
customers can do with a customer managed
control plane
however what customers will typically do
is start to adopt our cloud services
start to to utilize citrix data
and so what they do in that process
is they're shifting away from having
this stack of a customer managed control
plane their virtualization control plane
database servers front end web servers
delivery controllers management infra
you know there are a few other bits and
moving moving pieces to that
they trade that whole layer that they
used to manage out
for a couple of virtual machines that we
call cloud connectors that live up
inside of their gcp projects
so in doing so those cloud connectors
essentially function as proxies for the
communications
and allow the customer inside of their
private vpc up on google cloud
to
deliver applications build and maintain
a stack of vdas deliver applications
to users
and do so in a way where citrix is now
responsible for high availability for
security for patching for the the
evergreen maintenance of it right
so it's uh you know from the solution
perspective if you're starting from the
ground today you got those two ends of
the the continuum uh and you know
customers can obviously start at the the
vdi world and work their way up into the
daz world okay this is fantastic um if
somebody wanted to give this a try right
now
what would you recommend where should
they go and get started so i can
recommend a couple of things if they're
not ready to talk to a human they can
they can find the citrix dads for google
cloud product in the google cloud
marketplace
obviously citrix.com has plenty of stuff
on it as well
but if they're they're really interested
in digging down and getting into some of
the nitty-gritty
of you know how these pieces work
together and what these design patterns
are you know what is this cloud forward
uh design pattern uh we'll send them in
the direction of our solution hub
on our citrix stock site so that's that
whole whole solution hub is focused
specifically on the citrix on google
cloud solution stack
so those would be the the two places
that i would suggest people start and if
they're ready to move forward from there
they can also reach out to their their
friendly neighborhood google cloud or
citrix salesperson
awesome thank you so much rick for
sharing your deep citrix experience here
like i feel like my mental model of this
being a window into these guys wearing
remotely is still true but there's just
a lot more to it
and that is great to see
and
i think it's really
nice to have another example of
tools to help people focus on
the specific apps for their businesses
and their end users um and you know kind
of delegate and get some help with the
stuff that is kind of common patterns so
um
hopefully you know you can let citrix
and google cloud help out with managing
some of that
please check out the links below
we have links to all the things that
rick mentioned and thank you so much for
joining us with this episode of
architecting with google cloud uh if you
want more please click and subscribe
[Music]